so let's start looking at a short
sequence of DNA and the letters I'm
going to use these are the short hands
for the various nucleotide bases that
make up a sequence of DNA so let's say
that I have some thymine thymine
cytosine guanine cytosine thymine
adenine thymine thymine and let's throw
another thymine in there so that would
be our sequence of DNA and what would be
the corresponding sequence of RNA that
it would be transcribed into if you
remember this from previous videos pause
this video and try to figure that out
well the key thing to appreciate is if
we're talking about base pairs and DNA
adenine pairs with thymine cytosine
pairs with guanine but if we're talking
about pairing into RNA
well then instead of thymine in the RNA
you would have uracil so the RNA here is
well the thymine in the DNA would
correspond to an adenine in the RNA
adenine guanine cytosine guanine adenine
and now since this is an RNA stay
instead of having a thymine right over
here this would be a uracil adenine
adenine adenine so this process that we
just did
this is transcription transcription
transcription from DNA DNA to RNA now
the next step if we're talking about the
whole process of how does this
information actually have an effect on
the body is we're gonna go from the RNA
and translate that into a protein and
the way we do that we've seen this in
previous videos is every 3 of these
bases that's a codon and it codes for a
particular amino acid now to figure out
what amino acid it codes for we look at
an amino acid translation table and
there's different types that you might
see this is the most typical type so the
first base is a second bases a third
base is G first base a second base a
where in this cell third base is G and
so that will code for the amino acid
lysine so we could write
ly s short for lysine here and we could
have also gotten that from a different
type of translation table for example
you might see a circular one that looks
like that but we would have gotten the
same result AAG start at the center a a
G codes for lysine then the next codon
and if you're getting it as excited
about this as I am I encourage you to
pause this video and try to keep
translating this the next codon is C GA
c g a arginine arginine and then the
next one is you a a you a a well here
that this little black circular dot what
does that mean well that means stop
codon and sometimes they'll just write
the words stop there so this is stop
there is not an amino acid called stop
this actually signals to and this is
happening at a ribosome this is
signaling for the translation process to
stop this is the end of our of our amino
acid chain of our polypeptide chain and
so we will stop right over there but now
let's do some interesting things let's
think about situations where there are
mutations where some of these bases may
be something gets inserted maybe
something gets deleted
maybe something gets swapped out and so
let's start with what's known as a point
mutation so let's say this C gets
swapped out for an a well if that
happened then on the RNA strand all of a
sudden this would be a uracil and if
that is a uracil this a AG would still
be there coating for lysine but this
second codon is now different what would
it now code for we'll see you a see you
a it'll now code for leucine instead of
arginine lue seen Leu this is fairly
typical for a substitution mutation it
might change a particular amino acid but
sometimes it could be more significant
for example if this G was swapped out
for an A then this C on the DAR na would
then be
you and then what would happen well this
first codon would still code for lysine
but the second one would be you GA you
GA now all of a sudden it codes for a
stop codon and so the actual translation
process would stop which could be a very
very big deal if this DNA sequence if
the thing if the normal non mutated
polypeptide had to keep going on and on
and on over here just happen to have a
stop codon next but you could imagine if
they had just you know another thousand
codons before the end but all of a
sudden you had a point mutation to stop
early that would significantly affect
the protein that is coding for now
another type of mutation that typically
has a fairly significant effect is a
frameshift mutation and that's where
something gets inserted and or deleted
and shifts everything so for example
instead of the a being swapped in for
the G what if the a got inserted here so
then our sequence would look like this
T T C and then we have a and then you
have G C T G C T a T TT so what just
happened here this was our original
sequence but the a got inserted here
didn't replace the G and so everything
got shifted to the right now what are we
coding for well when we transcribe to
RNA this will be a a G you see G a you a
a a and now this first codon still codes
for lysine we've seen that multiple
times but what about this second codon
the second codon over here you see G you
see G that's serine we got a different
amino acid and what's interesting is
it's not just that one amino acid is
changing we're gonna see that keeps
happening so now we have a you a a you a
here we have isoleucine so iso leucine
right over here which is different than
what we had before we now don't have a
stop
codon anymore and we would keep going on
and on and so you could imagine a
frameshift mutation where you either
insert something or you take it out so
that the whole frame gets shifted can
have a dramatic impact on what it will
transcribe and then translate for now
lucky for us even though mutations are
always going on there are many
proofreading mechanisms in biological
systems to make them less frequent than
they otherwise would be and people are
still understanding how these
proofreading mechanisms fully happen
another thing to appreciate is we often
associate a mutation as being equal to a
bad thing and often times it is a bad
thing it what used to be a functional
protein may not may no longer be a
functional protein because the the amino
acids the the coding got stopped short
or there was a frameshift mutation it's
just coding for completely different
things so sometimes it could be very bad
and some diseases actually are caused by
strange mutations like that that show up
oftentimes the mutation might not be a
big deal maybe something it gets swapped
out maybe only one amino acid changes
and it doesn't really change the the
ability of the protein to do its job in
which case it doesn't matter but every
now and then a mutation that could
actually be a good thing in fact we need
the mutation in order to have variation
in a population and variation is what
natural selection and evolution run off
if you don't have variation then you're
not going to have different things that
get selected in different environments
and you're not going to have that
gradual change over time so a big
picture hopefully you got a better
appreciation for how transcription and
then a translation let me write that
down and then so that's transcription
from DNA to RNA and then this is
translation translation from RNA to to
protein to protein
we got appreciation of how that happens
we got a pre shishun of how to use these
translation tables but also how either a
point mutation or a frameshift mutation
can eventually affect the protein that
gets coded for